i don't know if you've ever noticed this
but it seems like the more things that
you have to do
the harder it is to do pretty much
anything like you have this
long list of tasks and responsibilities
that seems to be growing
longer and longer and longer and as it
grows in size
you also kind of get paralyzed and
intimidated by it
even just thinking about the list gives
you a mini panic attack and as you
mentally go through this list you think
to yourself man i don't really need to
do any of these things like
right now right i can probably get away
with playing a little bit of video games
a little bit of apex
because nothing's due right this second
and the thing is you're probably right
most things on that list you don't need
to do right this
second but the problem is the longer
this list gets
the more it subconsciously affects your
well-being
and pretty much every aspect of your
life you're not able to fall asleep as
fast as you once did
maybe it's graduated into full-blown
insomnia maybe you're plagued with
anxious thoughts like how the hell am i
gonna get
all this stuff done what if i don't get
any of it done will i be living on the
streets
maybe your entire life has been plagued
by the fact that you can never
seem to just sit down and do work ever
you always have a
large backlog of things that you need to
do and you are
always treading water maybe you've
looked around at your friends and
co-workers and wondered
how come other people seem to be
actually able to do stuff
is there something wrong with me so i'm
making this video because
those sorts of feelings are what has
punctuated my life
since birth i know what it's like to
always have something
do or overdo constantly and it's one of
the worst feelings in the world
when you're stressed about this
monumental to-do list that you have
it's even difficult to enjoy social
outings because subconsciously you know
that you really shouldn't be there
you should be tackling this list of
responsibilities it's like a knife in
your back that's slowly being twisted
as you fake laugh at the jokes that
people make around you it's not fun
luckily though i've managed to turn
myself into a relatively productive
human being
who can actually tackle the mountain of
stuff without feeling completely
overwhelmed so in this video i want to
share with you guys my main strategy for
tackling that mountain of stuff that we
have to do and
actually gain some traction in our lives
okay so what's going on here how do we
end up in this situation
so usually the reason why we end up with
a mountain of things that we need to do
that we feel
overwhelmed by is because naturally life
presents itself with tasks and
responsibilities that we have to do
there's no getting around that and these
tasks need to either be done
immediately or sometime in the not too
distant future
if the task isn't utterly urgent what we
tend to do
is put it on our backlog of things it's
this list that i'm talking about
we say oh we don't have to deal with it
right now let's just put it on
our to-do list and we will tackle it
sometime in the future but this in
itself is super problematic because
almost everything in life doesn't need
to be tackled
right this second very few things are
immediately urgent and require our
absolute attention
right this second which means that 99 of
every task that we get
we put on our backlog and since life
just naturally dishes out these
responsibilities we can always form a
graph that shows that as time passes
along
more and more tasks and responsibilities
start to accrue
there's also another graph that's
happening simultaneously
that says the more and more tasks that
we have to do the more stress we feel
and there's another graph
that goes the more stressed out we are
about our current situation
the more unpleasant the thought of
dealing with that situation becomes
we have two more left the more
unpleasant the thought of doing anything
about our situation becomes the more
likely we are to escape from doing
anything about it
and finally the more likely we are to
escape from doing anything about it
the less likely we are to actually do
anything about it basically
the more time goes on without dealing
with our situation the less likely we
are to deal with it anyways
and it just becomes this horrible
feedback loop so right about now you're
thinking oh his solution is probably to
just do the things before they accrue
do tasks right away as soon as you get
them and that's actually a great idea
but that's
that's not what this video is about you
know that's what my mom would always
tell me and she's actually right
you should just do tasks pretty much
immediately after getting them
don't let [ __ ] build up basically but
that doesn't really help us
if we're already in hot water if we're
already absolutely drowning in things
that we have to do in life and we need
to get out of it and that's where i
propose my golden rule
do less not more and you might be
thinking to yourself right now
wow that's a cute quote joey you should
put that on a poster unfortunately that
doesn't make any sense well here's the
thing
it doesn't really make much sense but
neither do we as humans
we didn't get into this situation if we
made sense if we followed perfect logic
if we followed perfect logic we would
just do things as they came to us
we would finish off whatever task came
up onto our desk
onto our lap like santa claus we got to
this situation because we're highly
emotional and
impulsive when we're in emotional
distress we don't respond well to
logical arguments
we respond well to momentum and feelings
of perceived
progress so we should do is take
advantage of this fact and
leverage our main weakness and turn it
into a strength
every single day we have at least one
task that we know we need to do
and if we were to do that thing all
other tasks would be made
easier or unnecessary we need to find
out what this task
is in our lives and we need to focus our
entire being
on completing this one thing and we need
to pretend that nothing else
exists and with this extra focus this
unified focus
we will be able to complete this thing
in record time
once this one thing is completed then we
will feel motivated and
energized to tackle more things in our
lives we will actually feel
excited to keep that momentum going but
it's impossible to gain that momentum
if we don't tackle that one thing and
finish it
every single day and i'm pretty sure all
of us can relate to this exact same
situation
i'm pretty sure we've all engaged in
escapism
avoiding that one thing that we have to
do and we escape and escape and escape
until the pressure builds and builds and
builds maybe a deadline is approaching
and then we just snap out of it we kind
of go into survival mode
and we just tackle that thing from start
to finish and we're done
and we are so incredibly relieved and
inspired by the fact that we did that
thing
that we think to ourselves holy smokes
why don't i just go do more things in my
life that felt
amazing and that's the exact emotion
that we're trying to tap
into it's that feeling of having
completed a very important
thing and then leveraging that momentum
to tackle more things
and i think we can only get to that
point if we kind of put the blinders on
and forget about literally everything
else on our list
we use our emotional compass to figure
out which thing has the most emotional
resistance
what thing are we avoiding the most that
is likely to be
not guaranteed to be the most important
thing that you have to do in any given
day
for me as i've talked about in other
videos that thing
is writing writing by far has the most
emotional resistance for me
i don't really like doing it but once i
have done it
then i have content to work with i have
something to film i have something to
edit and i have something to upload you
know writing is kind of the
backbone of my entire youtube career
it's the most important thing
that i can do in any given day as long
as i continue writing
i can continue youtubing maybe your life
is really consistent like mine
or maybe it's super turbulent and that
one thing will change
on a daily or weekly basis you know take
what i'm saying and apply it directly to
your life
and your needs right now you probably
have something that you know you need to
do
and you're really resisting doing it
maybe you've been resisting it for a
long time
that's your one thing do not worry about
anything else
complete that thing and once you
complete that thing the answer
and the motivation and energy you need
to complete everything else
will be provided for you in droves
putting the blinders on and forgetting
every other task except the one thing
also adds clarity
to the overwhelm it brings order to the
chaos
our brain can stop bird shotting
everywhere and thinking about a million
things at once and getting super worried
just calm your brain down focus on
completing
the one thing take everything that you
need to do and write it down
write down every task that you can think
of onto a piece of paper
and try to identify the most important
thing that you need to do and then what
i want you to do
is circle that one thing and scribble
out everything else
don't worry about anything else give
yourself a mental vacation from
everything else
do that one thing it's the only thing
that exists
and whether you are excited to do it or
not it doesn't matter
submit to it submit to just doing it
starting it completing it not a big deal
do it because if you have to do it
anyways there's no point in getting all
emotionally worked up about it you just
have mental clarity
you submit to the fact that you have to
do it you do it without resistance you
don't you do it without hyping yourself
up and once you complete it you will
feel
calmly empowered to restore more order
into your life this video was inspired
by
the one thing by gary keller so if what
i said really resonated with you and you
want to take it a step further and dive
a little deeper into this concept
then i highly recommend checking out the
audiobook version
using today's video sponsor audible
because that's exactly how i read the
book
i've said it so many times these days i
consume so many more audiobooks than i
read physical books
and that's because listening to
audiobooks is just so easy
you can be going for a walk you can be
driving somewhere you can be exercising
cleaning your kitchen
it doesn't really matter it's found time
you can be listening to an audiobook and
getting smarter
while you're doing the things that you
do anyways on a day-to-day basis
it's kind of a no-brainer and for those
of you who don't know audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment
and audiobooks ranging from bestsellers
to celebrity memoirs
to productivity self-improvement
whatever you're into
it's probably on audible every single
month they give you one
credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
price
and you get to keep that audiobook
forever if you ever cancel your
subscription for any reason
you still keep your entire library of
audiobooks you can start listening right
now with a free 30-day trial just click
the link in the description below
go to audible.com better ideas or you
can even text better ideas to 500-500
and the price for a subscription is
actually lower than usual right now so
if you're thinking about grabbing an
audible subscription now is the perfect
time to do it
just click my link in the description
below or text better ideas to 500-500
if you liked this video make sure you
actually hit like
because when you hit like the algorithm
says oh this was a good video and it's
worth people's time
and that uh and then my bald head gets
shoved into people's home pages
helping them out which also helps me out
so it's kind of a win-win for everybody
involved and if you're lurking here and
this is the thousandth time you've seen
my face
consider subscribing and also checking
out the second channel where we do more
q a stuff
it's a little bit more casual a little
bit more memey and we dive into just
i don't know fun chill laid-back content
other than that
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video
[Music]
that's good i don't know have you ever
noticed that
have you ever noticed that the more
things you need to [ __ ]
i'm gonna just do it i'm uploading this
[ __ ]